Jason you talked about filmmakers that
need to what you say quote source and
exponentially grow than their audience
so what do you mean by that and can you
give us examples it sounds very
complicated yeah I guess it does sound I
guess when you say like source and
exponentially grown all use it sounds
ridiculous which now means that every
blog post where I've written that or
every email where I talk and I do talk
about that a lot i use those words
really all I'm talking about the word
sourcing really means finding your
target audience finding that kernel of
people with every every project I've
been involved with there's always like a
dozen or so early adopters and in some
projects there's more but these are
people that are like super excited about
whatever it is you're working on your
movie so I you know I always bring up
Kickstarter and I think that's great
because it actually helps you find out
who those early adopters are and they
can become part of your marketing team
to help you exponentially grow the
audience which means if I have 10 people
that are early adopters and they're
super excited and they go out and get 10
other people to come in and those people
become equally excited and they get 10
of their friends and now now you got all
these people you got ten people bring in
10 more people in I you know math I
usually need to calculate or figure out
what that means but we're talking like
10 times ten times that you know and it
just grows and grows and grows and that
works but it's not an easy process so
sourcing and finding those people that
love you and love your work is
challenging and when you do find them
getting them to go out and promote what
it is you're doing it becomes a little
bit easier but it's not it's not it's
not guaranteed it's like you might have
some people that are that are really
early adopters they love your stuff but
then they get distracted you know they
get caught up in their own personal life
their their bills their family and
you're like oh weird you know Jim Smith
super excited about my movie go I can't
reach him three three weeks I'll you
again email back hey sorry sorry Jason
I've been real busy with such and such
and you know and now what are you doing
you got to go and find more and more
to replace and keep the keep the
conversation going
you